as we know people on the internet feel a
deep need to constantly be outraged
about things there's a certain amount of
outrage a certain quantity of outrage
that's required
to satiate this need as people you know
develop outrage tolerance though
they'll find that they need more and
more outrage to get their fix
now this shouldn't be a problem there's
no shortage of outrageous things
happening in the world all the time
you could no more run out of outrage and
you could run out of sand on the beach
but what happens
the problem is is what happens when when
the people who most need to feel
outraged
have also for political reasons
committed themselves to being
not outraged about the most outrageous
things
what happens when someone deeply needs
to be outraged but their ideology
precludes them from being outraged about
for example
the murder of babies and the general
mutilation of children
well this is like looking for sand and
you live right next to a beach
but you need to find sand everywhere but
the beach and even sandboxes
now you've just made what should be the
easiest thing incredibly difficult
and that's why in the age of cancel
culture people are forced to go back in
time
to find things to satiate their
outrage desires they gotta go back in a
time machine like back to the future to
find something to be
pissed off about every day there's
another video from years ago that's that
people are randomly upset about for no
reason other than the fact that they
need to feel upset about something
and this week that video or one of them
that fills the need
is uh this it's an interview with steve
harvey from i don't know when several
years ago i think like 10 years ago
and in it he gives his opinion about
whether men and women can be friends
platonic friends
he says no and people are upset so let's
listen first to the as they say
resurfaced clip my friends are men i
don't have female friends
i don't i'm i'm incapable of that
why what do you mean well because you
know come on because you have a wife
well i have a wife and i don't i don't
really have female friends because
look okay let's get rid of this myth
right here okay i'm gonna tell you this
let's get rid of this right here
that you're an attractive woman there's
some guys somewhere saying yeah i'm
we're friends
no that's not true he's your friend
only because you have made it absolutely
clear
that nothing else is happening except
this friendship we have
we remain your friends in hopes that one
day
there'll be a crack in the door a [ __ ]
in the armor
and trust and believe that guy that you
think is just your buddy
he will slide in that crack the moment
he gets the opportunity
because we're god think this way 99.9
of us think that way very upsetting
stuff there
uh people are we're upset about it also
correct of course it's obviously true
that men and women can't really
be platonic friends there are exceptions
of course there are exceptions
to most general principles okay but it's
impossible to talk about anything if
we're not able to make
reasonable generalizations and we can't
that's why we can't talk about anything
because people are always
obsessed with the exceptions that's
another one of the pedantic things
people do online that annoys me
you're talking about general principles
and someone says no i'm aware of an
exception
i personally am aware anecdotally of an
exception let me tell you all about the
exception i know about
no this is a reasonable generalization
and it's true men and women can't be
friends that doesn't mean they can't
work together doesn't mean they can't
function around each other it just means
that they can't they can't be
buds they can't be pals in the same way
that
men can be pals with each other or women
with each other
now when talking about this subject the
first thing we have to say is and don't
take this the wrong way ladies but
um your opinion doesn't count okay your
opinion doesn't matter here it doesn't
matter what you say
and i'll tell you why i know that a lot
of you
think men and women can be friends but
it takes two to tango
and sadly men much of the time have an
entirely different dance in mind
as for men who claim that they have many
dear friends who are women
some of those guys are gay and the rest
are lying
don't shoot the messenger here i'm just
this is just the truth
now if you're the sort of person who
needs a study to confirm your own common
sense well luckily we have those
according to an article on the
scientific american researchers recently
conducted an experiment
to find out how males and females in a
quote friendship actually felt about
each other so here's how that went
reading out says in order to investigate
the viability of truly platonic or
opposite sex
friendships a topic that has been
explored more on the silver screen than
in science labs
researchers brought 88 pairs of
undergraduate opposite sex
friends into a science lab in order to
ensure honest responses
the researchers not only followed
standard protocols regarding anonymity
and confidentiality but also required
both friends to agree verbally and in
front of each other
to refrain from discussing the study
even after they had left the testing
facility
these friendships friendship pairs were
then separated and each member of each
pair
was asked a series of questions relating
to his or her romantic feelings or lack
thereof toward the friend
with whom they were taking the study the
results
suggest large gender differences in how
men and women experience opposite sex
friendships
men were much more attracted to their
female friends than vice versa
men were also more likely than women to
think that their opposite sex friends
were attracted to them
a clearly misguided belief in fact men's
estimates of how attractive they were to
their female friends
had virtually nothing to do with how
these women actually felt and almost
everything to do with how the men
themselves felt
basically males assumed that any
romantic attraction they experienced was
mutual
and were blind to the actual level of
romantic interest felt by their female
friends women too
were blind to the to the mindsets of
their opposite sex friends
because females generally were not
attracted to their male friends they
assumed that this lack of attraction was
mutual
as a result men consistently
overestimated the level of attraction
felt by their female friends and women
consistently underestimated the level of
attraction felt by their male friends
what a shock and by that i mean
not a shock at all common sense wins
again this is so thoroughly confirmed by
common sense and the nearly universal
experience of all mankind
that it isn't interesting to talk about
whether or not it's true it simply is
what is more interesting to talk about
is why it's true
and the and the reason for that is also
a matter of common sense though perhaps
not so common
anymore it's this men and women are
different
men and women no matter what they might
say for political and ideological
purposes
all basically know that they're
different they see each other as
different and they see each other
differently
you know heterosexual men are perfectly
capable of bonding with women but their
desire is to bond in a different sort of
way
and i don't just mean sexually a man's
attraction to women
is hopefully not merely sexual his
desire for companionship with a woman
has a prominent sexual element of course
but there's more to it than that
yet it all tends towards arrows towards
romantic love
one of the problems i think we have in
society is that we only have one word
for love rather than in other languages
like greek where they have multiple
words for different kinds of love
a man's affection for a woman is going
to be different in kind
from the feeling that he has about his
male friends he's going to want
something different out of the
relationship that's not his fault it's
just
not it's not a flaw or a weakness it's
perfectly natural he's a man and as a
man
he relates to women in a certain way now
notice something
women who think they have male friends
will often say that they're they're you
know
what they'll say is i'm just one of the
guys and they'll brag about how they can
throw down beers and spit and cuss with
the best of them right
most of the time that's a lot of silly
nonsense but even if it's true
you see how a woman who wants to be just
friends with a guy
will have to try to imitate the
relationship between two men she'll have
to try to blend in
with the guys she'll have to try and fit
herself into the category of a male male
friendship
be you know basically become a man by
default for the purposes of the
friendship
why is that well it's because there is
no authentic
category of a close male female
heterosexual
platonic friendship that category
doesn't really exist
the ones that work if they work at all
work because the woman is basically
pretending to be
a guy and is seen as a guy by the other
guys
but usually from the guy's perspective
if they want to hang out with guys
they'd rather the guys be actual guys so
if a guy is letting a woman into that
fold
if he is putting up with that charade it
is
usually for a reason and it's not the
reason that the woman has in mind
now the male female friendships that
really work are the ones that are
mediated and contained and centered
around some other larger thing
men and women can get along at work even
be friends in the context of work
married couples can be friends with
other married couples in these contexts
the friendship can function and remain
just a friendship
but they can't be close friends just
with each other
without that mediation and context
married couples can be friends but if
the husband from one couple
starts hanging out alone with the wife
from the other couple
problems arise as a wife
if your husband is out late having some
beers with his guy friend
you might be annoyed that he's out late
but it's not going to be a crisis in
your marriage
if you find out that he's out late
having some drinks with a female friend
quote unquote they're gonna be sirens
blaring and red flags waving all over
the place
in fact even if you didn't have any kind
of physical or sexual contact
with that woman at all you're probably
already gonna feel cheated on
because he should not be having that
kind of intimate companionship
with a woman who is not you he
guys have a need for female
companionship but it's a different kind
of companionship
and so his need for female companionship
is supposed to be filled
by you he shouldn't need more close
female companionship if he does that's a
major problem
and ever almost every wife on the planet
sees it that way
even if for whatever reason they would
disagree with steve harvey on the point
he made
um there's no need to talk about whether
things should be this way things just
simply are this way men and women are
different they relate to each other
differently they bond
differently and that's fine
you know the reality only becomes a
problem
this is this is a general lesson for
everybody with in all things
reality only really becomes a problem
when you are set on denying it
and that's especially the case with
things with human nature
and we are set on denying so much about
human nature and that's why
everything is falling apart and all of
these things that should work basically
fine don't work anymore
because we're set on denying what is
obviously true right in front of our
face
and that is why i don't need to cancel
male female friendships because they
don't really exist
uh instead i'm just gonna cancel the
people upset about steve harvey uh
especially because that was something
from 10 years ago anyway so let's let's
keep let's get when we're looking for
outrage can we at least keep it within
the last i don't know there should be a
30-day cut off can we can we agree to
that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated